today's topic an article from my
favorite website HuffPost telling male
friends I love you is a muscle guys need
to flex every day a day comes on young
men stop forming nurturing bonds and
begin to connect by trying to break one
another we do this to another by teasing
bullying or ball busting which can cause
more harm than show affection actions
and deeds between France big volume but
the words left unsaid can echo for a
lifetime
it takes daily practice some women take
the day before Valentine's Day to
celebrate their close friendships in
their daily life they call it
galentine's day years ago I submitted
two men the case for Malin Tynes day as
a day to begin learning ways to proclaim
and cultivate and nourish our male
friendships through movements of
vulnerability we should say I love you
when we mean to need to want to if you
love the men in your life don't wait to
tell them each day I invite you to take
time to check in with yourself and what
you are feeling to check in with a male
friend and ask how do you feel today and
genuinely listen start with words then
work up to deeds and actions to express
love how about a real hug instead of a
bro hug how about telling your buddy
you need to talk how about not changing
the topic when your buddy opens up how
about like a dog no how about being more
open to hugs when your body your buddy
offers one no no no okay he's talking in
ways that you're talking way like we
don't show that as we show it
differently example like the other day
we had samples right hmm you pay mm-hmm
next time I'm gonna get you I got you
you said that the last five times and
you never pay this plane see this see
this hold on hold on you see this yeah
that's what it is what's wrong with it
bro hug what
with that stop demonizing everything
that man do in a manly way
oh that's good you don't want to show
you buy more yes we do you know what I'm
gonna tell you something that's really
weird but I think man value more the
word I love you than women hot take hot
take fresh I love it
the reason why we value it more is
because we use it less are you saying
that scar City creates value
yes value what the I'm saying Oh
like my mom used to tell me I love you I
love you I love you I love you okay bye
I love you okay do this I love you it's
fun cool but when my dad said it to me
what it means
oh I know he meant it woo cuz you know
if I oh I love this who I love Chanel I
love that perfume I love that wooden
shoes I love them everything is love
that means that everything is love but
when men use it is specific things mmm
it's not a bad thing that we use it
whenever like there's a dramatic thing
that happened because that's what we
should I Love You Man
it's hard to see you go cuz we use it in
a way that is powerful and meaningful
we're not gonna use it all within Lenny
so I believe in it I know it's a hard
thing but I really think that we value
it more I'm not gonna say it to a girl
just like yeah girl I love you cuz I
know the impact of that word and what it
means it's not just the word there's a
whole meaning to that sometimes I love
you isn't even I love you
sometimes I shared something was my
friend and he looks me in the eyes he
says I'm there if you need me and I know
what that means but he's like your shirt
store who's your friend
something like we don't share stories
when we have a you know when we have the
moment when whenever we chill with a boy
like someone look at yo this and that
happiness and that man huh yo bro you
know you know you know what I'm talking
about what that when that thing happened
with that dude and he wasn't a bad
situation he's like yo this and that
happening he's just sharing in that time
we go and when he's done sharing we're
like yo are you good that's the first
step
my dude telling me yo asking me if I'm
are you good
is anything how's your mom I think about
my mom my family asked me about all the
people around me then asking me and then
finishing it off with hey if ever you
need some bro
you know you get holla you don't have to
say I love you to say I love you oh I
love you that's your thing okay
but to me you said that about the
checkout first when it comes to emotions
I feel like women are exhibitionists
it's a display for everybody take a
wedding for example I was about to go
there with the ring they want the ring
throwback that's all how much you love
him I used to be a wedding
cinematographer everything needs to be
document guys are killing blase blase
they don't women need today and it's
okay the work groomzilla does not exist
the word groove villa is not a thing but
it should be a rapper's name villa you
have that perception of men and their
emotion in their vulnerability because
of that fact that most men don't show it
outwardly
or don't exhibit it but in private with
the right people we do show it and
that's how you want to do it and I just
find it so belittling that people feel
the need to write these articles to tell
men how we live in how we do things is
wrong when it's okay for us amongst each
other why would you tell us we don't go
telling women how their friendships
amongst themselves should work we don't
tell women be more stoic we don't tell
women how they need to behave in regards
to their girlfriends but everyone feels
comfortable telling them how they need
to express their emotions how they need
to do this and they always bring up
these bogus statistically men and stop
stealing and you see because they don't
talk about the emotions men are out
there epstein themselves and I'm like
what do you guys not realize that women
attempt it way more than men do it so
we're more successful no it's just that
when we do something we mean it love you
bro
oh gosh that give a real hug listener
times we're like you know what one of
those bro hugs and gets a little bit
more rough and that's me for showing you
like hell I'm here I've had that happen
girl when the handshake
makes noise does it matter to you
no but when you see your homie for a
long time and you're like oh that's cool
that's all but when you see your
homie this happens and that be on the
bad happens that was love you and if you
needed any indication of ballbusting and
stuff like that was super important the
reason why men's you become a little bit
more stoic as they hit 16 and 15 is that
for centuries
that was when men beat young boys became
men and so they had to become hardened
to the realities of the world and they
have to be more stoic because of the
fact that they were going to face danger
and so the way that you showed them love
is that you toughen them up and you
prepared them for the responsibilities
that they're gonna have to take on later
down the line but whatever you do their
skin yeah I'm just a brother you see all
these jokes were making about true hero
thin you life is gonna be worse so be
ready for that all of this right
here
the community that we have growth in you
you roll back you gotta roll back how do
you think you know when it comes to moms
moms are nurturing how do you think
fathers instill their lowering their
kids by teaching the importance of
responsibility by teaching them what
they need to know so that when they go
out there they're ready where moms are
nurturing almost to a point where it can
be negative for example maternal
gatekeeping well they're so protective
of their kids that they almost make them
unable to grow into adults because
they're too protective our fathers have
the opposite approach generally speaking
with what they're trying to do is
instill it within you the values that
you need to be an independent adult when
it's been like that forever and it can
also go overboard it's called an
absentee father that's what that's not
too much yeah
you're learning you people are not gonna
support it don't see it's important to
note that the into the end we have are
different and it doesn't mean that women
can't take that role and men can't take
that role if you want to be a dude who
says I love you all the time that's your
thing do that but don't try to impose it
on the rest of us society really like to
be like oh yeah well you know if men are
together in there acting like that is
boys will be boys will be boys that's
not necessarily that okay you're
watching too much TV okay we're not all
Stifler okay calm down
it's not always that and people that are
saying that it really don't this end of
the dynamic a big and it's fine just
stay in your lane boo-boo everyone wants
to hit on stoicism everyone wants to hit
on men who try to keep their emotions
together the war should go down what do
you need excuse me there's a fire how
about I tell you let some pop off
and let a man act more emotional to the
woman and she will lose all attraction
to that man guarantee real quick very
fast what do women always say they
wanted a man security protection how can
I protect you and be secure if in a
moment of crisis I'm more emotional than
you are I just feel like sometimes
there's like this huge effort from
liberal media's to make men more
feminine and I'm just like you let us be
what we want to be as long as it's not
in relation to how we treat you don't
tell us how to live and we won't tell
you how to live at least I don't but
some people do if men are talking to you
some type of way you have a say but if
it's how we talk to each other get out
of our business that's how life so
that's it we want to hear your thoughts
tell us what you think comments below
please
[Music]